okay we're doing the mission later bro
incredible oh sure let's get the crowd
going all right here we go and here's
the butcher of Stillwater swagger it in
and speaking of surprises here comes the
luchadores enforce the butcher came to
the help from the fans this is just
turned into a lumberjack match from hell
all right Bobby you know this is a
classic management in the reverse power
youth verse age brains first bra well
you know the fact that these two
attacked me partners it really adds
another layer to the whole to mention
they train together they know what to
expect one wrong move can end the entire
mass and you gotta wonder if angel is
gonna be able to keep his cool you know
you're right Bobby the last time these
two what I'm knife
oh [ __ ]
oh my god no angel is out of the ring I
can't believe this Bobby this is
punishing to watch the luchador man is
sick getting knocked around like a sack
full of dead puppies she's wait the
butcher of still water is making his way
toward I've got cattle much can one
person be expected to oh my god the
cheese off hook up ma ma
I hope the audience brought some paper
bag Bobby it is raining blood fatal flaw
in the luchador planet be fine count for
the murder brawl chainsaw it's got to be
getting slick on that floor hey I gotta
get my grandmother get my mom it was a
desperate move for a desperate time but
it looks like the Gamble has paid off
now this is what people came here to get
the butcher up stillwater on an
unstoppable rampage cubed can't be happy
to see this come for that spray way Tom
Lucius Jesus angel I think I broke my
leg get in there and kick that bastard
ass I can hold off these jabbers well it
looks like we're gonna see the fight
they pay for as the butcher of
stepdaughter stands toe-to-toe with
Kilbane no this is classic Saints
tactics use someone to weaken up the
opponent that swooped on in for the kill
I love it I already beat your champion
not leaving here without your [ __ ]
mask with you this is it folks two
giants in the field of destruction
facing on her our entertainment does it
get any better than this no it does how
only one of these two has the good sense
to leave the violence in the ring q
crane wakes up he touched it here comes
the hot look at the brutality from the
Blitzer I think it'd have to be naive to
believe a giant like Kilbane hasn't
thrown in a few punches here and there
outside the ropes body not like the
punches based organizer [ __ ] the bar
container seem to be 0 for 1 Q llegas a
bowing down to the foot sir anytime soon
but this celebrity of those streets
isn't making it easy on kilbane times to
be something more going on that too long
time and kill may go sailing how the
event
the way he's already heading back in
looks like the Stillwater venture isn't
getting a moment's rest tonight that's
right Zach there are no free rides
against the apocalypse you betcha no
matter who is tonight someone's going
home with crushed dreams and internal
bleeding the crop can shatter the
carnage and quite frankly Zach neither
can I can land the kill switch another
mess from kilbane the champion cannot be
happy with that one's out
ok
that guy yeah
00
that sound will stick with you come rose
there he goes
get Jenna tennis [ __ ] the whole measure
it foul is fair in love and motor brah
kill Baines not down again and here come
the lucha doors in his place murder
brawl is certainly getting the finest
han [ __ ] gonna [ __ ] the Smashing
Entertainment Tonight Bobby my heart
goes out for the cleanup crew on this
one Zach durban while you can still
insane and here comes the kill zone so
slow
this is incredible the Kilbane just
can't connect with the kill switch
so that's it there
oh my god
ah
hey she says can get white bear Bobby oh
goodness hi Cassie if your ticket wait
I'll give you the secret of the
Apocrypha just leave me my mask smile a
donation
it's shades of Angel has been dealing we
have seen the face of the walking
apocalypse and to be honest it's a man
with the receding hairline the saints
are still standing what a night what
oh my god you bein it's just a match
it's my [ __ ] action oh my god i am
its cesar oh and i get to fiddle while
it burn itself Jesus now thanks for
watching
it's out for Harambee